greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
all throughout December I General Zod
will be talking to you about the
oddities of this holiday you called
Christmas I do not understand your alien
ways so with every episode I'm going to
analyze another strange thing about the
way you've Estonians act so that I may
judge you harshly and in time punish but
let us look at your first oddity of the
strange holiday snowmen
these strange creatures are neither snow
nor man where they take that back they
are snow but they are not men they lack
genitalia I have yet to see a snowman
with a male member which is ironic
considering the amount that sticks
people shove in them I must say that as
far as armies go they seem very fallible
true they stand up straight and maintain
good discipline but they never move you
have to command an army and they simply
just stand there and they are made of
snow this is their fatal flaw I have
also noticed that their noses give fuel
to rabbits and provide many a hilarity
for Kevin and Hobbes cartoons but a
palpable army that does not make plus
they seem to have a strange allergic
reaction to the Sun it seems to be their
Achilles heel or even their I can't
think of any other comparison unlike me
or the son of jor-el who draws dry from
your mighty son if you had constructed
them say out of cybernetic warriors or
nails that would be a step in the right
direction
if there are snow Harmy comprised
entirely of me I assure you they will
not result in a puddle of piss and their
hearts would be colder colder you first
you and then one day your beloved frosty
final summer snowmen have no place in
the cydonia People's Republic of Houston
nay oh man on the other hand approved
deploy this is General Zod and you will
kneel before me